Let's go to the phone lines at (617) 830-4750.
Let's start today with our color from the
five five, nine area code caller from five,
five nine.
Who's this?
Where are you calling from?
Hi David.
This is Mike from Fresno, California.
I'll pay my good one.
What's going on?
Well, um, number one, I saw your, your podcast
on Joe Rogan.
I thought that was excellent.
Um, it's going to be great.
Washington, uh, Sam Seder, donk on Dave Rubin
Mar.
Yes.
Thank you.
I appreciate that the video was going strong.
Well, uh, I did have one topic on my mind
that I wanted to discuss with you.
Uh, I grew up as a Republican, was republican
values.
I went to college, saw how the Republicans
busted up their surplus after cleansing and
saw how hypocritical they were.
And I became more of a libertarian.
And over the time I, um, I've evolved into
becoming a fairly strong progressive, but
there's one idea that's a holdover and a,
it's one thing I can't get over to is no one.
Um, and the progressive, um, what's the world,
uh, blogosphere really talks about it and
that would be their inheritance tax.
Okay.
So what's your feeling about it?
Well, I find it interesting that at any other,
uh, topic where we discussed the flat tax
progressive's view it as being somehow unfair,
but when it gets to the inheritance tax, they're
totally fine with the 50% flax tax as long
as it's for people over, oh, with my family,
it was over $4 million.
Right.
Well, that's the whole point.
It's not actually a flat tax.
It's a progressive tax because it kicks in
only at higher income or wealth levels.
So it's just, it's not a flat tax.
It's flat beyond a certain point.
But that exists also, I mean, even with a
progressive, a wage tax, at a certain point,
it does become flat, right?
Like for ink, if you want to set the highest
bracket at $1 million, and at that point it's
50%, it's a flat 50% tax on everything above
$1 million.
So it's really no different.
I think it might be just like a semantic issue
that you're experiencing.
Um, well I'm wondering if we, it wouldn't
be better off using a bracketed tax structure
like with our federal income taxes where perhaps
people at a lower level only have to give
the government maybe 10%
sure.
Yeah.
I mean listen, you could, there's no question
that you could do it in a different way.
It would be a matter of looking at, you know,
if in total it's making it more regressive,
I would be against it.
But there are other ways where you could do
a bracketed estate tax that I would be completely
fine with.
I don't disagree with that.
In principle, it would just matter what the
brackets are and what are the tax rates.
Absolutely.
That sounds like more of an Elizabeth Warren
policy, one Curry's sort of topic though.
Yes, it is.
Which I love, by the way.
I think it's great that she's actually doing
the one query and people seem to be liking
it.
I agree.
I'm really looking forward to the debate,
but I feel like I've probably taken enough
of your shows time.
So a press, I'll call back again and I'm not
there, so.
All right, thanks Mike.
Appreciate the phone call.
Very great to hear.
I'm Mike from Fresno.
Very, very good.